[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
السلام عليكم ازيكم عاملين ايه انا اسمي
ماريه النهارده هكلمكم عن حاجه مهمه
بالنسبه لنا ومتعبه بالنسبه للامهات
والابهات وهي ادمان الشاشات طيب كل حاجه
ليها ايجابيات وسلبيات فالموبايل بتخليك
تتواصل مع مع اي حد في اي مكان عايزه بغط
الزرار وبيبقى في جيمز مسليه وتعليميه في
نفس الوقت وبت نمي مهاره الابداع عند
الطفل لكن خلوني اسالكم سؤال حد فاكر اخر
10 فيديوهات اتفرج
عليهم لا ده اللي بيحصل لما تدخل افكار مش
مفيده لعقلك وخصوصا لما تبقى فيديوهات
قصيره زي الشورت ريلز طيب انا عايزه اقول
لكم عن السلبيات بتاعه الموبايلات اول
حاجه بتهدر الوقت وده اللي بياثر على
التحصيل الدراسي والمذاكره وبيبقى بتسبب
ادمان وبتقلل
التركيز خلوني احكي لكم عن تجربتي مع
الموبايلات طيب انا كل اصحابي عندهم
موبايلات ماده انا خصوصيه كنت طلبت من
مامتي وبابايا بس هم رفضوا وادوني فرصه ان
انا اكتشف نفسي وفعلا بدات واحده واحده
حبيت القراءه مع ان ما كنتش حاسه اللي هي
كانت ممله والملل ده بس حبيتها وعلى فكره
عالم القراءه زي الموبايلات بالظبط لازم
تخلي بالكم لما تيجوا تقراوا عن
حاجه و وتعلمت الابيسون والخياطه او لسه
بتعلم وانتم كمان ادوا ابنائكم فرصه ان هم
يكتشفوا نفسيهم
و ماتسيبوش الموبايلات لوحديهم في ايديهم
ولو ما قدرتو تمنعوا الموبايلات قللوا
وقته على قد ما تقدروا عالم بره الشاشات
واسع جدا مستحق ان انت توريه لامنك
[تصفيق]
شكرا